all right kiss kiss show where'd you
grow up are you from originally New
Mexico which city albuquerque
albuquerque and tell me about your
childhood he had both your parents
growing up yeah I had both parents kind
of dysfunctional upbringing but I made
the best of it how was it dysfunctional
um I was molested as a child for my dad
and grandfather by your dad and you're
different
mm-hmm and I ran away when I was 14 came
out here and I had a modeling career for
a while how long did the molestation go
on till I was 14 from as young as I
could remember
Jesus so did you say anything did I
didn't say anything until I was 23 and
when I it was already too late but I got
away from it hmm and then you when you
went on your own where did you go out
here CVL a long time yep and how did you
end up on Skid Row
um actually I applied for housing and
got housing through descubrió Holly so
so where are you staying now I'm right
down the street over here on 7th oh no
no no you have an apartment oh you have
an apartment mm-hmm you're one of the
few yeah and do children over young
mm-hmm
have four therefore then did you raise
them um three of them I did one of them
I lost my parental rights but she
reached out and contacted me this year
yeah she she found me mm-hmm
so hold your kids um I got a 27 year old
a 21 year old a 19 year old and a 10
year old and so they're using drugs
yeah which what's your drug heroin
heroin
mm-hmm and how long you've been using
now mm-hmm maybe 12 years how do you
support yourself um well I escort
sometimes a lot of the girls kind of use
that yeah there's a way to make money
it's something guys can't do usually
yeah really good but yeah it seems to
pay the bills sometimes never yeah
and how is that is that something so you
do that [ __ ] through like no matter Plex
I'm sorry
Humana Plex its coresight okay I don't
know it's um you know you have to be a
member for it but um it's a guys call
you out of the blue
what well everybody's a member on the
site and like your profile it's like a
social network type of thing but it's
for escorting so so you'll meet a guy
arrange a dress and yeah do your
business and oh he gives you the money
and that's now yeah
it's safer than walking the street right
oh yeah yeah is it better caliber of
clientele then iíve never worked on the
streets done escorting I'd stripped for
a little bit but for the most part yeah
I feel like the site that I work for
it's safe
you know um like I said everybody's a
member on there you know and um I I have
yet to meet with somebody who's not
attractive no really
yeah no problem yeah they start at 300
an hour that's a lot more than the girls
here they can yeah on the street
yeah please here in this neighborhood
yeah yeah there's no way I would even
work down here yeah you're not gonna
make that kind of money no I'm not at
all mm-hmm and how many years have you
been escalating um by about five or six
and you're stripping as well
mm-hmm what's what's the difference
money-wise and um headache wise and
what's the ups and downs of clothes well
stripping you know comes the
the whole lifestyle you know bars
staying up you know till 3:00 at 4
o'clock in the morning you know bar
lifestyle as opposed to escorting you
know you could pick your own hours you
know pretty much and it's them not as
much work huh
definitely not as much work right just
doing sex work kind of get get to you
after a while or just about it you get
depressed or anything sometimes but for
the most part no no I go into mode you
know kind of like them I I don't mean to
be judgmental because I think everybody
doing anything for a feeling huh no um I
just the mindset I think it's all on the
mindset you know I just kind of tune out
yeah tops of yours oh yeah yeah it helps
when you were a child did you have like
dreams of doing something else with your
life oh yeah I had dreams it you know I
was gonna it was gonna be a cosmetic
chemist I was gonna do make make makeup
and uh huh
what do you think got in the way of that
ever happening I think um the
molestation you know where my
self-esteem you know my self-worth yeah
yeah yeah it's hard it's hard to
maintain that yeah self-worth after
something like that happens right yeah
definitely mm-hmm I mean do you see that
your life would have been totally
different if that those events had not
happened for sure yeah I would think
that's for sure it's a powerful yeah you
know I look at my kids like then you
know my kids have been fortunate you
know you know and I they're all pretty
successful so you know so I know that
they've had a decent upbringing
these are did that right yeah
it's topped with your generation yeah
that's great yeah
and where do you see yourself going from
here heroines the hard drug to kick I'd
like to quit you know it's rare that you
actually do see people who are on heroin
quit you know it's very rare but uh I do
have hope I have hope that I'm gonna you
know get off the drugs and you know do
something I definitely want to go back
to school Oh your parents are you kids
aware that you are using um they're
aware my my drug use out then they don't
condone it
no but um they don't play rogue no no no
thank God
yeah okay yeah what about your parents
do your mom my parents are both awesome
password living this lifestyle I do you
think it's changed you in some way um
yeah but not really because you know
pretty much you know you know it's it's
similar you know like when I was a child
and being molested it was like I had to
kind of tune that out you know so yeah I
mean what are your views on love do you
believe that love exists functional
uh-huh I mean I I'd love to say that you
know you know that you know I got the
whole lofting down pat but you know my
my perception of love you know I know
it's not really what love should be you
know but um you know I know that the
love that I thought for my kids you know
it's genuine you know and there's no way
I could ever ever violate them you know
I I don't even know how my dad and
grandfather you know cross those
boundaries I don't get it but you know
um as far as like as far as like in a
relationship I don't know what normal
relationships like you haven't seen that
work out no no like where relationships
have been like for me five years five
years five years
yeah it's a common story isn't it yeah
all right cash thank you so much for for
talking with me and good luck with
wherever you go from here okay good luck
maybe some good good luck you can care
what all right I think I needed it
yeah thank you